[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to tonight's
episode of beginner breakdown my name as
per usual is Alex mullering and I'm
excited to be sharing this lesson with
you today uh this one is geared
especially towards people who are just
starting their chess career
um you know how to move the pieces you
know about check and Checkmate and what
those words mean you know all the basic
rules
um but you're really trying to figure
out if if I'm looking at any given
position what's a good place to start to
try and figure out uh what to do and
I've done other videos on you know game
analysis and kind of evaluating
positions and this is going to focus on
one specific element that I think can
really take someone who doesn't know
much and turn them into you know a
reasonable Contender when you're looking
for moves
we're going to start by talking about
unprotected pieces
whenever you're playing a chess game
this is usually more often in the middle
game or end game but there are some
opening traps about this there are times
where you will put a piece on a square
where it is not defended that means none
of your pieces could capture it if it
was
um
taken by an opponent's piece and using
this we're going to look for both our
own pieces that are unprotected and our
opponents and that's going to be a
really good starting point so I'll
explain it as we go but I want to start
with an opening example
so this is an opening called the
ponziani opening it starts with Ponte E4
black plays Pawn to E5 Knight to F3
attacking the pawn Knight to C6
defending and here there's a lot of
usual moves you can play a Spanish game
with Bishop to B5 or an Italian game
with Bishop to C4 oops
uh you can play a scotch game with Pawn
to D4 you can play Four Knights you got
a lot of options here but the move Pawn
to C3 Begins the ponziani and the idea
is kind of interesting
while this does occupy the square our
Knight would like to go to it does add
an extra Defender to D4 and the hope is
that white will be able to play D4 and
then recapture and maintain a strong
center with their pawns so this is what
white would like to do now one common
response is to play Knight to F6 and to
say well the norm of you would like to
play as white here is to defend this
Pawn by playing Knight to C3 so now you
can't do that and instead of defending
this Pawn white often we'll play Pawn to
D4 anyway continuing with their plan and
hoping to generate some counter play
now there are lots of ways that both
sides can go about this and already have
changed made different decisions but one
particular line that is relevant for our
discussion today is Knight takes E4 so
black captures this pawn and instead of
recapturing on E5 black or sorry white
plays Pawn to D5 displacing uh black C6
Knight with the idea that in the future
we will recapture on E5
probably the best move here is to play
Knight to E7 but
um
let's imagine Knight to B8 is played
this does get seen every now and again
a very tricky move here is to instead of
recapturing the pawn immediately which
might run into some danger after Queen
to E7
and there being the queen online with
our King and some discovered check ideas
white place to move Bishop to E3 and
sets a trap
because now a very very natural move is
for black to say oh well you didn't you
didn't take my Pawn so I guess I'm gonna
defend it I'm not gonna let you do it
and uh there's a few ways to do it you
could maybe play like Bishop to D6 or
queen to E7 but these moves seem a
little suspicious because you know you
don't generally want to block in your
own pieces if Queen goes to E7 then this
bishop is going to have a hard time
developing and if the bishop goes to D6
then this bishop is going to have a hard
time developing because this Pawn is on
the way so instead block plays a very
natural looking move Pawn to D6
and in this position
there is a serious problem because black
has fallen right for the Trap they've
played this natural move and the way we
highlight that is look for the
unprotected pieces
there's a very obvious one in this
position which is why I like to start
with it and that's this Knight here on
e4 certainly if we were able to take
that piece nothing would defend it
and here's kind of a principle I want
you to apply when you're looking for
tactics
in your chess games if your opponent has
uh more than one unprotected piece
or if they have at least one unprotected
piece and their King is exposed
then there's often tactical
opportunities so really be aware of
times when the king is exposed meaning
there's some Avenue you can use to
attack it with a check or something
similar and
or possibly a Checkmate threat
and there's unprotected pieces in this
example the move to win for white is
Queen to a for check
attacking the king and hitting the
Knight this is a classic Fork where one
piece of ours attacks two of our
opponents and they can only save one so
in this case black will play some move
to protect their King
but we will happily eat up this night
and white is doing quite well we have a
piece for a pawn
so this is something we are very happy
with and the way we found that now this
is certainly an opening trap so probably
whoever is playing this already knows
what's going on
but it's possible that this scenario
just happens in a game
regardless what I want you to focus on
is look out for again opportunities
where your opponent has one or more
unprotected pieces
or even if they just have one and their
King is exposed then there's often
opportunities for tactics
so uh I want to show one more example
here this is maybe a more natural middle
game a lot of things have been traded
black is up a pawn presumably because
they were able to take upon here on B2
with their Queen at some point in the
game
but it's kind of complicated white might
have a slight lead in development and
control of the center so it's arguable
who's doing better here but either way
in this position black plays a really
problematic move
instead of taking this Free Pawn on D5
although maybe there are some issues
with discoveries black decides to play
Knight takes E4 and simply trade the
pieces and their expectation is white
will recapture and the game will
continue black is up material so they
should be happy to trade and simplify
the position
but here if white takes a second even in
the middle of a capture which seems so
obvious to just oh I just need to
recapture
and looks at the opponent's unprotected
pieces we might be able to learn
something really fascinating
so
if we look at Black's side of the board
certainly this Rook is unprotected
although it's also pretty hard to attack
so good to keep in mind but not an
immediate issue
this bishop on E7 is unprotected okay so
that's good to know this queen is also
unprotected
but you'll find that generally speaking
it doesn't matter so much whether the
queen is protected or not because she
has such a wide range of Mobility now
there are times where it can matter but
um the queen being unprotected is
usually not your first instinct that I
have a tactic here because she can
usually respond effectively
but okay so this bishop and this Rook
and now it's white starting to move into
consider how we want to capture this
Knight and so maybe some people would
think okay well I'll just capture with
the bishop and centralize the piece
looks fine to me and there's probably
nothing wrong with that
but if we look a little closer we might
realize that if we capture this with the
queen
then we now create two threats one is
against this unprotected Bishop
but now notice we also have set up a
battery where our Queen works with our
uh sorry the Knight will the queen will
be on e4 where the Knight is I'll just
play that on the board
and now this battery is set up towards
our opponent's king and we threaten
Checkmate so this is kind of like that
example where I was saying it doesn't
always have to be an exposed King in
this case the king is doing fine it's
just there is a Checkmate threatened so
because we are able to line this up and
there's an unprotected piece here black
will not be able to stop both threats
they'll need to do something to save the
king perhaps Pawn to G6 and we can
happily gobble up this extra bishop and
now white is doing really well
so again these are the things you want
to watch out for in your positions even
in just something as innocuous as a
simple capture than a simple exchange
look out for where your opponent's
unprotected pieces are
and see if you can find ways to attack
multiple of them at once or generate
threats against the king
and those pieces so now we're going to
look at a few different examples for any
and all of these if you're watching this
live then feel free to guess in the chat
what the answer might be in this
position it's black to move and if you
are watching this later on YouTube
please feel free to pause the video I
might not stay on these for super super
long but feel free to pause and try and
find the best move for each example
so in this case it is Black's turn to
move
and our first question again is to try
and identify where the unprotected
pieces
once again this queen here is not
protected
but hard to attack a queen if we have a
knight sometimes that'll do it but not
so helpful
okay what else is unprotected let's see
at first it might look like this Pawn is
unprotected but the Knight covers it and
all of these pawns actually happen to be
protected save this one on A2 so maybe
there's a chance to attack that but I
think the really critical factor of this
position is that this Knight on D2 is
not protected and as someone already has
found in the chat uh
excellent name
um has suggested Queen to G5
noticing that it both attacks this
Knight and because our opponent's Castle
is somewhat destroyed we have these
doubled pawns here
Queen to G5 will attack both the Knight
and uh our opponent's king and similarly
they cannot save both
so the king will have to make some move
wherever it goes we will take the Knight
um so again hopefully this kind of
concept makes sense we're going to be
kind of drilling the same thing over and
over again
so our next example here it's White's
turn to move and again we want to look
for those loose pieces
welcome in learn practice
LM prove
improve learn practice improve wonderful
knit
so here it is White's turn to move again
and there's a lot of pieces on the board
so it can look complicated but a really
nice way you can simplify what's going
on
is to
start by looking for your opponent's
undefended pieces
okay we have Queen to B3 suggested
although that's not a legal move so I
think you might have just mistyped
yes uh you edited it Queen to B5 and uh
so
lydian Don and Gabrielle hollar I
apologize for any mispronunciations of
any of your usernames I have found Queen
to B5
once again hitting this unprotected
bishop and this exposed King we have a
an Avenue to attack and so Queen to B3
or sorry Queen to B5 will take care of
it whatever move black plays here say
queen to D7 we can pick up the free
piece
okay so and this is something as a note
that you want to apply both to your own
position and your opponents so some
players will really hyper fixate on the
attacking opportunities they have and
look for their opponent's undefended
pieces and just go after them without
any regard for their own
self-preservation it's a really good
idea also to be aware of which pieces on
your side are unprotected or if your
king is exposed
and keep an eye out for your opponent's
threats because they're going to be
doing the same thing you are
okay
here's our next example here the last
few of these have been focused on
finding a way to attack an unprotected
piece and exploit the fact that the King
has some exposure issues
this one the king is very well guarded
and it's really hard to find a way to
attack the king but there is an issue
with some unprotected pieces here in the
black Camp so whites turned to move if
you have any suggestions or ideas for
how we might punish black for not
protecting their pieces just kind of
some people will call these hanging
pieces or hanging pawns or loose pieces
loose ponds but whatever terms you would
like to use see if you can find the best
way for white to progress in this
position
all right we have some suggestions in
the chat once again reminder if you're
on YouTube always feel free to pause
but Queen to D1 here is the correct move
noticing that this Knight is on the side
of the board you is correct James Lee
this is yeah we don't like Knights on
the edge a night on the rim is grim in
most cases and it's not protected by
anything so it's a loose piece and queen
E1 hits the Knight and also picks up
this bishop on D6 which is also
unprotected I also think this bishop is
kind of you because uh the pawn is
unable to move
so yeah this piece placement is not
great and queen D1 exploits that really
well
um if they try and save the Knight we
can take the bishop
and if they try and save the bishop we
can take the Knight
again this is all happening because of
forks that we're seeing and we'll see
some other examples of tactics we can
use to go after unprotected pieces but
the general principle all of it starts
from seeing which pieces are
particularly weak in our opponent's side
of the board all right white to move
here
yeah free pieces are incredibly yummy uh
I highly recommend eating them up eating
as many of your opponent's pieces as you
can find
so uh White to move here and again find
the winning idea because blacks pieces
or at least one of them is not very well
positioned
and especially it's not protected
so in this position white to move a lot
of candidate moves in a normal position
right if you're not really paying super
close attention castling looks like a
great idea and it probably is maybe
pushing this Pawn or maybe moving the
queen to try and find a way to develop
this bishop there's lots of potential
ideas but when you start to look at
these positions by noticing that some of
the pieces are unprotected then you can
find really nice ways in and several
people in the chat have found the move
it's Queen to H5 both hitting the king
and this bishop which is unprotected uh
the bishop on F5 is defended whether it
because by the Knight so whether it goes
here or stays here you can't take that
but whatever is played to defend the
king the bishop on H6 does fall
I'll write another example here in this
position again white to move
and some people are probably immediately
going you seeing this gross night on the
rim once again and that's a good thing
you should react quite strongly when you
see these poorly placed pieces but it's
not really effective unless you know how
to punish poorly placed pieces
and I guess we are working on principles
for punishing poorly placed pieces
in this position
all right enough with the alliteration
uh Kaleidoscope guy I think I've seen
you in the chat before glad to have you
back and great idea Queen to D5 hitting
the Knight and also very cleverly
hitting this Rook on A8 in some of the
earlier examples we might not have been
paying as much attention to these Rooks
because often they're guarded but in
this case because it's unprotected and a
second piece is unprotected we have an
excellent Avenue to attack
uh Bishop G5 suggested by Jay Smith is
not a bad move you are attacking the
queen it just unfortunately there are
ways to stop that problem perhaps uh
just dropping the Knight back to F6 and
some of our tactical opportunities will
disappear
so that's okay I'm glad to have you make
a suggestion here uh and take a guess
but Queen D5 is better because we are
going to be able to win a piece by force
you cannot save both The Rook end of the
night
all right another example here
uh and this one involves something I've
talked about in previous lectures called
forcing moves which is a very famous and
very important topic in chess so if
you're unfamiliar feel free to check out
that lecture or there's lots of books
and content on forcing moves it's a
really critical idea but we're going to
use that to our advantage here to find a
really nice opportunity
this is probably the hardest puzzle
we've had so far so if it takes you a
little bit more time don't feel bad in
the slightest but it is black to move
material is completely equal
and James Lee I believe you have the
right idea but
I want someone to be more specific I
think you know what it is but I just
want to see some notation here for how
to do it
so does anyone have the right idea
give it a little bit more time and then
we will reveal the answer
okay uh someone else in the chat
vinicius
excellent Name uh May dieros benicius uh
welcome in Queen to E1 is the perfect
start here check and this is a forcing
move so forcing move just very quickly
is any move that forces your opponent to
respond in a limited number of ways
checks are usually uh the most famous
example of that because they have to do
something to save the king is against
the rules of the game not to in this
case after Queen to E1 this King will be
forced to H2 and from here we find that
this king is exposed and this Rook being
unprotected is vulnerable to a fork on
E5
the King again has to move somewhere and
we pick up the Rook very looking very
good for black
okay excellent job one more example of
this kind of uh similar thematic
although this time notably there are
Queens off the board so this tactic of
or just this General principle of
looking for unprotected pieces does not
require
um that you have a queen on the board
she is very very helpful because she
attacks on the diagonal and the vertical
and horizontal lines so she covers a lot
of ground and can hit pieces on really
different parts of the board
so often those are probably the most
common examples but something like this
also when applied with forcing moves can
help us find other ways to pick up
unprotected pieces
and this one is again kind of tough
all right a few people in the chat uh
cabbage rule Taylor Webb both of you
want to play and James leave and he see
us all you got it Rook takes C8 check a
forcing move I mean black could move the
king out of the way but then you just
lose a rook so Bishop takes the natural
move and now Rook to d8 check winning
the bishop by forking and I really like
this puzzle in particular because in
this position no one's paying attention
to these two pieces because they're both
protected right the bishop is defended
by the pawn and it's defending the Rook
this Knight is unprotected and it looks
like it's the big Target but fusing your
forcing moves and calculating that if I
take this Rook they have to take back
and then the bishop becomes undefended
and this King being exposed becomes a
big issue it can lead you to find these
really nice ideas
okay
we're going to look at now a slightly
different idea this one is not too hard
but let's see what you all can do black
to move and in this position we're
always going to be looking for the
unpredicted pieces but there's something
different about what's going on here and
how we're going to be able to win them
so
black to move and play the only winning
move
oh yeah in the previous example yeah it
looked like Checkmate
um unfortunately the King still had a
square but we did manage to pick up a
bishop so black should still be winning
quite well
no worries at all okay uh yeah a few
people have found this one as well and
the idea is Bishop to F6
and this is actually a pin
so a pin is another kind of tactic the
thing about unprotected pieces is
you can really apply so many tactics and
learning about tactics is going to help
you when you see an unprotected piece
know which one to apply to what
situation in this case we are attacking
this Knight and we are pinning it to The
Rook
um neither of these pieces are protected
and if the Knight moves anywhere then
the more important piece The Rook Falls
but if the Knight doesn't move it's not
protected and there's actually no move
that does protect it The Rook would love
to come to C1 and defend it through its
own Pawn but that's unfortunately not
possible so whatever move is played uh
white will be losing material at least a
night and possibly even a rook
all right here's a similar example
white to move and play the only winning
move
is this a forced check trade leading to
an end game
previous example let me think really
briefly
no I think you can just win this
material and Black's gonna be able to or
sorry White's gonna be able to keep the
rook in that example
but
um you'll be up a piece
okay
in this position yes back to this one
white to move and we have a suggestion
here Rook to D1
so again when we first look I think
forcing moves are a great thing to look
at trades and exchanges but we notice
that again black has an unprotected
piece that's the the theme Here of this
lesson is unprotected pieces so
constantly be looking out for those uh
with this Rook on d8 and not only is
that I'm protected it's also very hard
to protect because the king is pretty
far away
and so putting the Rook on D1 pins the
bishop to The Rook if Bishop takes
Bishop
then we do not recapture instead because
if we recapture here then we actually
are in big trouble
uh we first take the Rook because this
is check after the king moves then we
recapture the bishop and we have an
extra rook and extra Rooks are really
really good Rooks
uh one tricky thing about this situation
is if King to f8 is played just waiting
you want to be careful about how you
take this you can take it either way but
if we take with the bishop then black
has this annoying move King to E7 and
now there's a bit of a counter pin on
our Rook on D1 because it is unprotected
one critical difference though is some
of you probably have spotted is whenever
we move this bishop we can carefully
place it somewhere either here on A6 or
sorry A4 or on G4 where it defends The
Rook itself
so not a perfect pin from Black's end
but it was a better try than before some
people might have just given it up
but probably simpler is to just take
with the rook and you don't have to
worry about any of it
all right one more example here uh again
on this type of theme we're looking
through
it is white to move
and see if you can find the best idea
starting by looking for unprotected
pieces
and exposed kinks in this case there are
both
but the king is not the most relevant
part of this position
so white to move
and if they didn't have this move then
black would have a serious Advantage
because black is up a pawn and has this
nice three on two over here
but unfortunately as James Lee and
Kaleidoscope guy have both pointed out
Rook to f8 is pinning this Knight to
this undefended Rook on A8 now the
Knight can't move because the Rook is
undefended if if this Rook were defended
then it's okay to move the piece because
it would be a trade even a rook for a
rook
sometimes a pin has you know you're
pinning a more valuable piece like a
queen or a rook by a bishop and so you
don't want to move that piece either way
in this case if the Rook was defended
this wouldn't work but because the
Knight can't move they're in serious
trouble
um so whatever move block plays
unfortunately there's not enough time
because uh your follow-up will be Bishop
to F4 attacking the pinned piece and
black has no way to save both
all right so now let's jump into some
quick combination of the previous two
examples so we looked at some pins and
forks and how they can be used to apply
tactical pressure when your opponent has
either an exposed King unprotected
pieces or some combination and here we
are going to apply both of those at the
same time we can spot that our
opponent's king is somewhat exposed and
their Rook here on C7 is not protected
and as someone Kaleidoscope behind the
chat has already pointed out Knight to
D5 as a an excellent move the Rook is
pinning this C6 Pawn so it cannot
capture our Knight which means that
after the king moves we pick up the Rook
our next example here and in the live
audience if you have ideas on our
positions as well please feel free to
comment uh in this position it's black
to move and our theme today is
unprotected pieces so we're starting by
looking at which pieces our opponent has
that are not protected and seeing if we
can find a way to exploit that with a
tactic be it a pin or a fork or some
other idea
right a few people a chat have the right
idea so this is a kind of complex
position this work on A8 is a little
funky it's not defended but also fairly
hard to attack without moving our Knight
um this bishop is attacking our Knight
this Knight is guarding the king but
sadly there is a pin in this position
our Rook on G8 is or I should say sadly
for white this is great if you're black
um our work on g eight is pinning the
Knight on G3 to the King which means
this Knight is not guarding E2 like it
normally would allowing us to play
Knight E2
and Fork the king and Bishop and we will
pick one of them up again exposed King
and unprotected peace often means you
will be able to find a tactical idea to
win you some material
all right so now we're going to
introduce a third type of tactic we've
looked at forks and pins and how they
relate to these pieces this one is a
third and before I spoil what it is
let's see what you all in the track can
find white to move and play the best
move
how can we win some material here as
white this one's a little harder
but again if you're having trouble I
recommend starting by finding your
opponent's unprotected pieces
and seeing if you can exploit them in
certain ways
all right so in this position a few
things going on uh there's actually a
lot of unprotected pieces in our
opponent's camp
uh this Knight is not protected this
bishop is not protected and this Pawn
here is not protected the Rooks defend
each other and everything else is
defended by one of these pieces the king
or one of the Rooks
and so it's kind of hard to keep track
okay I have these three to look for but
something else we can notice is we can
only really attack one of them I guess
you could play Bishop to F4 and attack
the spawn but like we said if we can
just attack one that's usually not good
enough because our opponent will find a
way to defend
we want to play moves that make multiple
threats
so in this case
uh James Lee I think you have the right
Instinct with wanting to take that pawn
if we take on G6 then there's a problem
one we took a pawn which is always good
but two we are threatening to capture
not only a second Pawn but also open up
our Rook to take this Knight on F6 it is
not defended so after F takes G6 this
Knight gets hit and black needs to do
something about it
if they move the Knight then they're in
serious trouble because if this Knight
goes say to G4 now this Pawn is attacked
by our rook and pawn and we can Fork the
king and Rook
so that's no good
um so instead probably something like
King to G7
and from here we can even add more
insult to injury as white so see if you
can find a really nice move in this
position
Indiana Jones 2022 OMG right back at you
so what can we do as white this is a
little bit of a bonus Point here to try
and find the best move
Bishop to C3
pinning once again this Knight even
though it's protected it's only
protected once by the king and now it's
attacked twice it's pinned to the king
so it can't move and there's just no
other good way to defend it probably the
best here is to choose to sacrifice The
Rook Rook 2 or I'm sorry not rookie six
uh but Rook E5 just getting in the way
and at least you're picking up this
bishop for The Rook so you're down in
exchange but
white is doing quite well here
okay
uh next one oh and if I didn't say I
think I may have but just in case this
uh type of tactic is called a discovery
so we're going to move one piece out of
the way and reveal the attack of another
piece which is going to be really really
helpful
all right in this case it is black to
move again a pretty complicated position
white is up two pawns and they are
marching down the board trying to
promote into a queen
black is pretty short up defensively and
we have our Bishop you know nicely
infiltrating these light squares but
it's not quite enough at the moment
what can we do to gain an advantage and
again remember start with the
unprotected pieces
wow this is actually a really hard
example I
so if you're if you're having trouble
with this one I apologize but
I said something at the beginning that
might be leading people to find or have
trouble with this example but
okay so F3 has been or probably F4
suggested or maybe E3
um a few other thoughts suggested but
this is a really tough one
so let's to try and figure this out if
you're not really sure I know a lot of
people in the chat are shouting out the
best answers
um and we'll get to it because you are
correct for most of you
um but we want to start by looking at
what are the unprotected pieces okay
this bishop is unprotected this queen is
unprotected this work is unprotected and
uh looks to be it
so how can we exploit that well we don't
really have a good way to attack uh The
Rook here on G5
or I'm sorry the bishop here on G5
but we do have a way to attack this
undefended Rook
and this queen in the same move with a
discovery this is a very hard one to see
but the move here is Rook to D1 so
congratulations to there's a handful of
people in the chat who found this really
really impressive we are discovered
attacking this undefended queen which is
normally hard to do it's normally hard
to get a a queen to be the target of
this type of trick
but the reason this works is because
white can't solve both of these problems
the queen has a bunch of places it can
move but none of them defend this
unprotected Rook
if you take our Rook I take your queen
and if you take my queen well what would
I do then
Queen takes E8 how do I continue
it's a very nice sequence yes we do not
recap for the queen and then we will
lose our Rook over here instead Rook
takes e one check and unfortunately for
white this is actually going to be the
game even though they still have this
queen on the board
their King has no legal moves because of
our Bishop so The Rook will have to drop
back and we capture it and perform
essentially the operating pattern where
our Bishop and Rook work together to
deliver checkmate
so really really nice idea there all
right uh one more example on discoveries
again these ones are a little harder
than the previous examples
but let's see what you can find
this is this is a fun one
so we're going to look for unprotected
pieces and exposed Kings and see if we
can use that to our advantage
this is also again a little tough
because there's a few type of moves
involved but I think you'll be able to
find it
start by identifying which pieces are
unprotected
and as you're thinking I'll start
thinking along with you
um a few suggestions in the chat and
I'll just kind of let that fester for a
little while
um okay this Pawn is unprotected because
Queen this bishop
and
that looks like it except for one very
crucial piece that is involved in
solving this puzzle
the queen is again normally hard to
attack now in this case she is fairly
cramped we control a lot of these spaces
but without a dark squared bishop or you
know the fact that our Knight can't
attack her on the next move
probably going to be tough to get after
the queen
this bishop is another good looking
candidate
we would love to try and go after this
piece but white has really good control
of the files of the end files with their
Rooks so that's also pretty tough to try
and find a way to break in there
but a few people are pointing out we
have a very nice idea because white
actually has one more unprotected piece
it's not just the bishop the queen in
this Pawn all right I'm sorry both of
these pawns
but actually
Knight on F3 this is technically an
unprotected piece because our Queen is
pinning the g-pawn to the king now
there's a problem we have
because the only piece we have that can
take this Knight is our Queen
but if our Queen moves to take it then
it's not pinning this Pawn which means
we look very silly
but
as a few people have found Knight to F4
really really beautiful move here opens
up this diagonal for the bishop to
attack this unprotected piece
and at the same time makes a counter
threat the Knight and queen are working
together to threaten Checkmate on G2
okay well you can either just push this
Jeep on which seems very bad because I
will be able to play check and still
take the Knight and
not really sure what you gained from
that
so it only makes sense to take this
Knight on F4 and now instead of
recapturing the bishop we play this very
very nice move uh oops I'm sorry
uh where's our position yeah Bishop
takes F4
and we play this very nice move Bishop
takes on F3
attacking the rook and threatening
checkmate
and this is yeah a very very difficult
situation you can Again Play G3 although
that is going to lose to Queen to H3 and
there's not any way to stop mate on G2
you could also Play Bishop back to G3
but then we get to capture this rook and
win The Exchange
um and you could play an Intermezzo an
in-between move you could play Rook
takes E8 but that doesn't really solve
the problem because I will simply
recapture and these two threats are
still active and you have to find a way
to solve them
which there really are none
so this is a really really nice example
of how to exploit these unprotected
pieces and especially pieces that look
protected right you know this seems to
be a very clearly protected piece but if
we remember our tactical vision
keep an eye out for these pins we can
recognize what's actually going on
beneath the surface
all right a couple more examples and
then I'm going to show you some real
games and what's gone on and how to how
this has been applied at all levels of
play
so uh this is
let's see
an opening example that don't worry too
much about what's particularly happening
I believe this is just yeah French
defense
with C5 you know very normal stuff
both sides attacking and defending
and in this position white Overlook
something you know very normal
development ideas pinning this Knight
but then it's unpinned and unfortunately
here uh there is an unprotected piece
that we can take advantage of
and it's a really funny tactic I've
included this in a couple different
lectures this idea because it comes up a
fair amount in beginner games and it's
really useful to know but this actually
is related to the Discovery idea we have
looked at what are the unprotected
pieces on white side of the board
okay the two Rooks certainly but hard to
get at them
and that seems to be it except this
bishop
so this bishop is not defended maybe
there's a way to exploit that
um okay someone says take on D4 and then
Queen D5 check that's a nice idea except
uh after they recapture then this Square
frees up for the night night we'll go to
C3 and defend so that would look
something like this
and even though the bishop is
unprotected Knight to C3 will save the
day
so it's a nice idea but there's actually
a more forcing one which uh Teo I
believe in the chat has found Knight
takes E5
and now
we win this Pawn
and there's a problem if you take the
Knight regardless of how you take it
your Bishop is undefended
so I will capture it
and I have one upon effectively
if you take my Bishop then the Knight I
just used that was on C6 boomerangs its
way back to D7 out of Harm's Way and
I've picked up this Pawn for free so
this is a very nice kind of tactic it's
really common I don't know if it has an
official name but it's just kind of this
discovery idea and in this case we find
it because our opponent has this
unprotected Bishop here that allows us
to exploit
all right
um
let's take a look at one more example
and then we're going to talk about some
of the ways this has actually happened
so in this position it is black to move
and again there's some complications
going on here
uh I'm sorry and this position it's
white to move I apologize
um in this position the move white
played was Rook takes F6
thinking that we're just going to do a
normal trade of Rooks
and the game will continue
but unfortunately
white just overlooked something
so we will
yeah we will talk about the idea here
there's a very simple but very crucial
in problem with white side of the board
here so after work takes this Rook trade
what is the problem that white has
yes
they have unprotected their Rook on A1
which is what this Rook was doing before
so again in the middle of a sequence of
exchanges you always want to keep an eye
out on these unprotected pieces because
if we notice that if we play a normal
game we might just take this rook and
then we're down to some material still
we have this Knight versus this Rook
uh or I guess it's material is equal
because we got a bunch of Pawns but it's
a little unclear
but instead Queen takes A1 check we hit
their King first and after they move now
we pick up both Rooks
so a really nice tool to remember always
look for the unprotected pieces and I
think this is actually more valuable to
think of from the white side
in this type of position it can look
very natural to just say okay let's just
trade pieces here but you really want to
be aware of your opponent's checks and
your unconfected pieces so the fact that
this queen is attacking this rook and if
our other Rook moves it will be a check
is something you want to take note of
before you decide to go through with any
captures
okay uh last few comments in the next 15
minutes we have here together
um this one is just a really kind of
common trick in the opening and again
I'm thinking of this more from the side
of we've looked at how to pick apart
unprotected pieces in our opponent's
camp now let's do some work to prevent
leaving things hanging on our end
so something that probably everyone who
has played a handful of chess games has
encountered before E4 E5 Queen H5
early Queen attacks aggressive Queen
attacks some people get really
frustrated by this type of thing because
they know it's not so good but they also
struggle to find an answer to it
in this position one of the critical
ideas is to remember
what are the unprotected pieces here
what are the threats so that's kind of
two different questions but the only
thing that's unprotected on black side
of the field right now is this epon even
though we know Scholars mates are coming
and there's threats we can deal with
those as they come
but we don't want to leave anything
hanging so if you play some move like
Knight F6 or G6 you're going to be in
serious trouble because you didn't deal
with which pieces of yours were
unprotected
but taking a second to look and say okay
this Pawn is unprotected I will just
defend
even if they make future threats you can
still find the time to deal with them at
the right moment
so yeah developing and eventually the
queen hang itself this is usually what
happens but I would recommend if you
want to avoid falling into any of these
pitfalls looking at the unprotected
pieces on both sides of the field it's
going to do you wonders
one more semi-tricky example here
in this position
it is White's turn to move and there's a
really nice idea so let's start by
finding the unprotected pieces
and then see if you can find a really
good move for whites
you'll probably find the move and you
might not see the problem and it's not
exactly a problem
but let's see okay so Bishop G4 I think
you mean Bishop G5
I'm attacking the queen this seems like
a very solid idea
um
perhaps just the queen goes to F5 and we
initiate some kind of trade but you know
you're making a forcing move
so nothing wrong with that
but there is something that looks a
little more tempting when we look at
what's unprotected here
to me when I look I see okay the Rooks
are defending all of this is defended
the pawns are all defended really
everything is safe except two pieces
this Knight and this bishop neither are
defended
and then I noticed wait a minute this
Pawn on D4
if I just take on C5 now I'm attacking
both the Knight and the bishop
and it seems like you can't solve both
problems
but now put on your critical thinking
hats because this is still probably the
best move
um but unprotected pieces as I've said
goes both ways black has a really
excellent move here so putting your
thinking caps for black and say okay
maybe you messed up maybe you missed
this but you actually have a way out of
it
what should black do here to
stay in the game not give up a piece
anyone have any ideas again this is a
tricky move
but we're looking for something black
can do even though these two pieces are
both hit
I'll tell you there's not really
any checks that'll do anything like
Queen to F5 yeah you can force a trade
and get the Knight out of the way but
we're still going to pick up this bishop
um
Queen
C3 you must be a Madman uh maybe there's
some crazy checkmating idea but I would
be too afraid to try
um
so a few people have found it in the
chat no you're good James I'm glad you
were commenting
um this is what we're here for we're
learning
um Bishop B5 is actually the move in
this position because what's happening
is we have found two unprotected pieces
on black side of the camp and they say
wait a minute this bishop of yours isn't
protective either there's nothing
protecting this piece so when I play
Bishop to B5 it sort of sets up that
Boomerang idea like before okay if you
take me now I take you and the PC we're
attacking is safe
and if you take me I take you here
either way black maintains General
material equality minus this one Pawn
that was initially traded and they might
be able to win that back
um but that'll just see we'll just have
to see how that plays out
um so don't give up even if you fall
into a blunder or make a mistake look
out for opportunities where uh you can
still make progress and especially again
unprotected pieces it goes both ways you
really got to be aware
all right uh one
I want to show you two positions from
two grand master games now
um this first one was a game uh between
uh Anna ushinina and Peter Fiddler and
we're gonna go I'm gonna skip kind of
through the moves it's a very solid
opening
um
where Ana gets a really nice Center
um
but maybe is a little bit cramped with
the pieces
the game continues black is up a pawn
for a while but again Anna has some
extra development
and we reach this position
so in this position it's White's turn to
move and
uh there's a few things going on
but I would start by looking at what are
the unprotected pieces
this Pawn on G6 this bishop on E5 this
queen on a two
uh and this Pawn on H6 all of these are
unprotected
keep that in mind
white decides that this Pawn on E6 is a
weakness because if I can take in its
track and uh maybe I can use the bishop
to attack it but I can't move the bishop
right away like something like Bishop to
G4 or you know Bishop to E2 to maybe
come this way these plans aren't going
to work right away because
rook and queen attack F2 if the bishop
moves out of the way we're going to be
in trouble I mean maybe you could play
Bishop E2 but then there might be some
other problems with like Queen to D2
or I'm sorry there's a queen here
regardless
um the first move played has worked to
F1 just defending F2 not worrying about
this being a later issue and hoping that
the Bishop's gonna move so white would
like to on their next move Play Bishop
to G4 and put some pressure on this E6
Pawn
black plays the move H5 to prevent it
and now white plays a really excellent
move
in this position take a minute to see
what you can find this is a hard one
but white plays a really excellent move
capitalizing on the fact
that white there that some of Black's
pieces are unprotected or could be
unprotected
so take a moment this is a hard move to
find but see what you can come up with
white to move
thank you
all right start wrapping up your
thinking caps okay G4 been suggested in
the chat G4 unfortunately undefends this
bishop on E on F3 so maybe Rook can take
I'm not really worried about any like
checks that white has because then The
Rook can just drop back so I'm not
convinced by G4 but it's an interesting
idea
and if Bishop to G4 then I will just
take with the pawn
so this is a very hard move to see but
the move actually played in the game
ah Teo actually found it yeah Bishop E2
question mark exclaim
this piece is unprotected we're just
hanging it but this queen is doing a
very important job defending this Pawn
on E6 because
if this queen moves out of the way of
Defense of this Pawn
and takes our Bishop then not only do we
take this Pawn but we take it with check
and hit this unprotected Bishop
uh oh
we've won a pawn at a Grand Master Level
that's a generally decisive advantage
so Bishop E2 and you can't really take
this
okay black plays Rook F7
Queen to C8 check Rook to f8
Queen back to C6 once again threatening
this Pawn threatening the same maneuver
as before if you take the bishop
so instead Bishop to D4 is played now if
you take the pawn then you at least you
don't get the bishop
but this runs into Bishop to C4
forking the queen and the pawn
in the game now this does allow some
trades here but these were calculated
ahead of time by Ana and so what happens
in the game is Rook takes F2
Queen takes E6 check kind of in between
and King to H7
uh you can't really play Rook back to F7
here even though it's check because this
is not defended
um so instead King H7
and white plays another very good move
Queen to D7 check
exposed King an unprotected piece
means you're probably going to find a
tactic
uh White just wins in this position I
believe svidler resigns because if
um
say
Rook F7 now attacking we just take it so
that doesn't work
and really what else is there
um
you don't really have a lot of options
Bishop back to G7 then you lose your
queen
so really really nice uh win by Anna
over Peter Fiddler in that game
let's look at one more example another
grand master game this is Marcus rocker
versus Yvonne Popov
and again we're kind of going to gloss
over the opening of this game
but we're going to reach our critical
position not as much it's going to be on
the board
and if you're not able to kind of follow
along too well with finding these moves
that's okay these are just kind of Grand
Master games that show even at the
highest level applying this principle of
finding unprotected pieces is super
super useful
in this position white finds a really
nice move the king black is up a pawn
um but there are some issues in the
black side of the board and
Marcus decides to sacrifice the Knight
on G5 F takes Queen takes uh two pawns
for the Knight but this king is now very
exposed
King goes to h8 to hide
and in this position it is white to move
there are two equally good moves here
um so see if you can find either one of
them white to move and find one of the
two equally good moves
but you got to say why so you have to
say more than just the move you probably
have to say the whole line
so I'll give you a minute to try and
figure this one out
okay Bishop D7 suggested
all right and James uh because you've
been getting a couple of these wrong
confidence boost here for you Bishop D7
is one of the moves it's actually the
move that was played in the game so
that's one of the two
uh okay Rook F4 looks good threatening
with Bishop
and threatens working yeah Rook H4 seems
like a big threat
yeah Rook of four seems actually very
good I think there is a problem with
this move this is not one of the ideas
um
ah black can get out of this a tough one
to find with Rook to G8
uh counter-attacking White's Queen but
otherwise a nice idea
so not Rook F4
Rook E3
also not confident about
well we found the move that was played
in the game
um but the reason is the same so Bishop
takes D7 I do want to explain
the idea is this
um
if this Rook captures
then this Rook will be unprotected
if you take uh here first which is what
happens in the game
then Rook takes and
there's a bit of a similar problem
although now if this work takes instead
of taking here we just have a
checkmating idea
so Queen takes D7 is what was played
but then Queen to E5 and we pick up the
unprotected Bishop
so all the way back in this position
this whole idea is just because this
bishop is not protected enough now you
can't just take it right away this this
is not good uh or I'm sorry it's
protected by the queen my apologies
um
so we either displace the queen or we
displace The Rook in either way black is
in a lot of trouble if they try and save
it so using this idea of unprotected
pieces or in this case at higher levels
cleverly forcing our opponent to
unprotect their own pieces can be really
really valuable
so the really key themes from this whole
lesson again if those last five ten
minutes went over your head that's okay
these are Grand Master games and they
are applying lots and lots of these
tactical puzzles and principles and
strategic ideas at the highest level but
really the key idea is just to know that
if your opponent has unprotected pieces
or an exposed King and hopefully a
combination really take a second and
look out for tactical opportunities to
punish them likewise if you have
unprotected pieces or your kings exposed
to be really watchful for your opponent
to create those tactical opportunities
themselves
I thank you all for joining us today
hopefully I will see you again sometime
soon but uh until then take care
[Music]